in Olympic boxing Cuba is a heavyweight
the nation's pride often rests upon
success in the ring oh my god and few
have known as much success as the man
who was just walked in Felix Yvonne is a
living legend one of the world's
greatest amateur boxers three-time
Olympic gold medalist six-time world
champion but serve on has been more than
just a champion in the ring he has been
the face of Fidel Castro's revolution
time and time again he rejected
multimillion-dollar offers to turn
professional
it said he turned out 25 million dollars
to fight Mike Tyson and he did it he
says because he believes that much in
the revolution I know I'm supposed to be
a journalist here and objectives put on
such a fan and that's the one I would
think I believe me and seen you know a
certain lawyer I was there it was a
great victory tell a champ I don't know
if he drinks or not but I'd like to have
a little drink with a second associate
edelman odometer I live with Terry yeah
so my second battle Travolta si all
right let's go I'm bill please champ
we told you I'm victory to victory
why didn't he take the money in their
professional vulgar or el amor I'm well
it was a lot for these people be bad
gala premiere homeland comes first
you're gonna say I was born in some
decent a very small town you can receive
a one-time obey from his neighborhood
just across the way with a big kind of
pointing his neighborhood home they were
living in a hot actually the place were
the slaves used to live
what ya know he went from a hut with a
candle to bring the face of his nation
and the face of a revolution yes sir did
that help shape his view of the
revolution Massa Carla become infamous
you can make your own conclusions
welcome BAC siete ocho americano
I thought 18 Americans on the ring and
direct loss oh you are a Padilla and
Sava
when he used to enter a ring with an
American his first so we'll go to a real
castle yeah so he was the frontline as a
revolution will you sit with ezio yama
every year via will put his hand on his
shoulder
we used to talk yeah happened do what
did we learn from the revolution yeah he
doesn't think that the current political
system is going to fall but we remain
socialist or communist but with the mix
yeah
so the real evolution will be an
evolution on the road
Felix Yvonne is a face of the revolution
a nationalist and a loyalist
[Music]